hi my name is Silvia you I'm the
chef/owner of churro borough here in Los
Angeles this has been a project long in
the making
I had gone to culinary school in New
York and came back to Los Angeles and
decided that instead of working in
another restaurant I wanted to do
something for myself
so for me you know I thought of it more
like what are components that go really
well together a lot of times you want
something that's warm and cold and
something with texture to something
that's smooth and so kind of digging
into my memories and things like that
the churro kind of came up in my head
more often than once it has that crispy
factor that flaky factor is a lightness
to it but I thought you know what a
heaviness to it as well and it balances
and pairs really well with ice creams
and so one day I decided to make some
trails from my family and decided to put
a scoop of ice cream on and it tasted
really good and after weeks and months
of just research and development the
true ice cream santa came about we make
everything in-house a small batch from
scratch it really ensures the quality
and the freshness of what we do